we have this kind of TurnKey
totalitarianism that is waiting there in
the wings where if a you know if a bad
dictator took over um you know now they
got AI they
GPS that's following you everywhere even
your you know your cell phone is
listening to your conversations and
recording them and knows everything
about you you know I I I was I mean all
of us have this experience I was talking
to my wife we need a new mattress and
both us got you know in bed at night and
both of us got three mat mattress ads on
our phones the next morning so and it's
not just the mattress company who's
listening to you it's the NSA who
storing all these conversations so it is
terrifying but I think there are if we
get smart people in a room like Elon
there's uh there are
things that we can do to at least
mitigate the um the the intrusive
impacts and the controlling capacity of
this new surveillance
technology
we play clips of all the politicians on
my show obviously and I always find in
the few moments and I I can get it with
you and I can get it with disantis where
it's like oh there's somebody that's
telling the truth and when you hear the
truth you you you're not contorted
you're not Twisted it's easy to hear the
truth and everything you just said there
was true and unfortunately you now know
with with the algorithms of Tik Tok and
everything else they've brainwashed a
generation not not to believe any of
that um but what it was making me think
as you were talking about the history
because I don't know how many people we
can win over the history maybe there's
something else we can win them over with
can you talk about why you think it
matters it may Israel May matter to some
of these people who are Jewish here but
why does it matter for America and
Americans because I also see another
version right now of of sort of the
libertarian version of oh just forget
that land forget all that it has nothing
to do with America I personally see it
very differently I'm wondering what you
think about that yeah I mean you know
the My Philosophy with with America is
that we need to unravel the Empire so we
have 800 bases abroad we pay 10 times
for our military we pay more for our
military than the next 10 Nations
combined
combined oh you know we don't we can we
can cut our military expenditure in half
from from well it's now 1.3 trillion if
you include um if you include the you
know the National Security expenses
usaid and uh and you know the National
Endowment for democracies which I will
my uncle started them I will end them
because they are completely perverted
what they have what they become they
don't do anything good for our country
but I I you know I'm going to cut our
military budget substantially down to
500 billion which is the same that it
was when during the height of the Cold
War when eyes an hour in 61 was in there
and um and we can what we need to do is
arm ourselves to teeth at home we can
protect our borders make ourselves too
expensive to ever invade and then
protect the sea Lanes protect the uh the
neutral areas like the Arctic and make
sure that we have the the resource that
are critical to us including the oil
resources that are critical to the world
that we have a uh strike capacity to
make sure to be able to protect
those and Israel is critical and the
reason it's critical is because it's a
bull workk for us in the mid East it's
almost like having an aircraft car in
the mid East it's our oldest Ally it's
been our Ally for 75
years um it is been an incredible Ally
for us in terms of the technology The
Exchange and you know and building the
Iron Dome which we've paid a lot for has
also taught us enormously about how to
defend
ourselves at home for missile so those
military expenditures um are are are you
know are are all going 75% of it goes to
us companies under the agreement under
the
mou but if you look at what's happening
in the midd East now Iran is now um a
the closest allies to Iran are Russia
and China Iran also controls all of
Venezuela's oil asbah is in
Venezuela they have propped up the
Maduro regime and so control that oil
supply um bricks Saudi Arabia is now are
joining bricks so those countries will
control 90% of the oil in our in the
world if Israel
disappears the vacuum in the mid East
which is you know Israel is our
ambassador it's our presence our beach
head in the mid East and it gives us um
it gives us ears and eyes in the mid
East it gives us intelligence it gives
us the capacity to
um uh to to to influence Affairs in the
mides if Israel disappeared Russia and
China would be controlling the Mast and
they control 90% of the world's oil
supply and that would be cataclysmic for
US National Security so that's the
answer to you uh why don't we hit one
more topic and then I think we're going
to take a couple questions from you guys
uh you mentioned a little bit in in your
talk about big Tech and you you've been
fighting big Tech as hard as anybody for
for quite some time do you ever feel
that we're we're too deep in it now in
some ways to reverse some of the effect
of the censorship and what we learned
from the Twitter files and the
algorithmic tricks that we know of but
as I always say I'm more worried about
the ones that I don't know of and how
they might be shadowbanning you at this
very moment and how much the the
agencies are still probably entangled
and even Elon has said he thinks he
might have moles still at Twitter even
even now uh do do you really see a way
out of that juggernut so ous I I think
we it's very dangerous and you know what
we can't really afford to be a war right
now with Russia and you know in these
kind of conflicts with China and even
Iran we we need to be sitting down with
each other and figuring out how to
control AI you know and we can't TR we
cannot Chase AI out of this country we
cannot make this a hostile enironment
for AI because super intelligence is
coming it's
terrifying but we better have it better
here than anybody else if we want to
protect our national security because we
don't we're going to be owned by
somebody else whoever controls that
super intelligence is going to control
the world and Humanity may not be able
to control for
Long we have this kind of TurnKey
totalitarianism that is waiting there in
the wings where if a you know if a bad
dictator took over um you know now they
got AI they
GPS that's follow you everywhere even
your you know your cell phone is
listening to your conversations and
recording them and knows everything
about you you know I I I was I mean all
of us have this experience I was talking
to my wife that we need a new mattress
and both us got you know in bed at night
and both of us got three mattress ads on
our phones the next morning so and it's
not just the mattress company who's
listening to you it's the NSA who is
storing all these conversations so it is
terrifying but I think there are if we
get smart people in a room like Elon
there's uh there are
things that we can do to at least
mitigate the um the the intrusive
impacts and the controlling capacity of
this new surveillance technology I you
know I had dinner with Jack dorsy the
other night and I asked him that very
question you know how would he control
it and what he said to me is you need to
have absolutely transparent algorithms
and we need to give people a choice
about what kind of what their algorithm
is and make it completely transparent so
if you want to if you want to have a
republican algorithm um you can have
that if you want to have a democratic
algorithm you choose it yourself um if
you want to have uh an algorithm that
just is neutral and produces the you
know the most red news or science news
whatever you choose it and you know what
it says and you know what it's going to
do that makes it much more difficult for
it to um uh for them to manipulate you
we're now all being manipulated we're
all being manipulated by algorithms that
we don't
understand and um and right now the
algorithms have nefarious uh objectives
so they have an agenda you know and the
agenda may be just to keep you
interested to keep your eyeballs on the
site that's the least Sinister agenda
but it's very s Minister cuz as we know
the way that you keep people on the site
is by reinforcing their biases and their
prejudices and that you know amplifies
the polarization that is now tearing our
country apart if you and I are living
right next door to each other and you're
a Republican and I'm a
Democrat we both ask the same question
on Google we're going to get entirely
different results because the Google
algorithm is decid is sending us things
that it things are going to hold us on
the site and as it turns
out people like reading things that
reinforce their existing prejudices and
their existing biases their existing
worldviews and and so but and
then you've got all these other people
the intelligence agencies who are now
designing the algorithms that are
manipulating us you know and saying you
can't see this information we don't want
you to see this we want you to believe
this and those things are really
Sinister so the you know what dorsy said
is that the the best solution to that is
to have us able to choose our own
algorithms and that way at least we know
how we're being manipulated we're
manipulating ourselves rather than
having some you know nefarious group
manipulate
us and I said that's a brilliant
solution you know why don't you tell
Congress about it and he said I've
testified five times before Congress and
I've said the same thing every time and
it doesn't make a ripple so anyway if I
get in there I'm going to do that
stuff if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop screaming
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell